après des mois de fermeture en raison du
coït 19 les puces de saint-ouen ont
rouvert leurs portes en mai dernier à
l'origine des puces un camp de
chiffonniers créée en 1885 sur les
fortifications parisienne mais à partir
des années 70
cet ensemble de marché touristique s'est
transformé à la base le marché aux puces
de saint-ouen
c'est un fourre-tout de vieilleries à
même le sol une mine d'or pour les
chineurs venus y chercher la perle rare
premier changement au début des années
70 la vente de vêtements se mêlent à
celles d'antiquités conséquence une
nouvelle clientèle apparaît de plus en
plus de jeunes viennent déambuler le
long des échoppes et ce qu'ils
recherchent
en 1974 les commerçants s'inquiètent en
cause l'apparition progressive d'un
marché clandestin au coeur même des
puces une concurrence déloyale dénoncé
par ce vendeur depuis dix ans il sait
gré un tas de jeunes qui vendent
n'importe quoi et pour que le marché
rage dans sa tradition je pense qu'il
faut annuler cette perte d'identité
elle est aussi pointé du doigt plus tard
en 1991
cette année là un nouveau marché est
inaugurée au sein des puces c'est propre
c'est neuf mais selon cette visiteuse
l'esprit du lieu a quelque peu disparu
c'est froid c'est seulement comme peu de
ça sent trop le plâtre le 9 on ne sent
plus du tout les la poussière et
d'objets anciens
cette transformation du marché entraîne
un changement en clientèle à partir des
années 90 terminées les chineurs de
l'époque place aux touristes étrangers à
la recherche d'objets design ou haut de
gamme
une clientèle aujourd'hui nécessaire aux
bonnes affaires des puciers en 2009
crise économique oblige les visiteurs
étrangers avaient déserté les allées
[Musique]
mais nettement moins on ne sait plus que
ce qu'attendaient on sait plus ce que
c'est que un américain en a pas eu
depuis septembre crise économique de
2008 crise sanitaire de 2020 même
conséquence pour les commerçants avec la
fermeture des frontières
les touristes étrangers ont déserté les
puces un manque à gagner énorme pour les
commerçants
chaque année le marché aux puces de
saint-ouen en attire plus de 5 millions
de visiteurs
[Musique]